[Music]
ken is in california hi ken welcome to
the dave ramsey show
hi dave how you doing great man how can
we help
uh i have a question um me and my wife
were we just started your program
about the middle of may and
we're looking we have multiple different
debts we have
auto loan debt student loan debt and of
course
mortgage that we're now considering um
now
our student loan debt they have
uh the accomplices about forbearance and
we were
thinking about doing forbearance to help
pay down that auto loan debt first we
just want to know your opinion moment
it doesn't matter it's pay me now pay me
later everything you don't pay on the
student loan in terms of principal or
interest you'll have to pay later
and so all you're doing is just in a
sense you're borrowing against the
student loan to pay off that
the the because you're paying less on
the student loan that you do have to pay
later
so you know you're dragging your feed on
it so you can speed up the other one it
doesn't matter if that's if you want to
knock that
car loan out that's not a bad idea um
but just you know don't ever be under
the illusion that the student loan folks
are doing you any favors
it's not the business that they're in
i see okay yeah so i mean all
forbearance means is
the word means patience
i see okay yeah and so if you delay it
now
you know use it to your advantage don't
just delay it to kick the can down the
road ken that's what people do
with student loans like they do with so
many other decisions they figure if they
can kick the can down the road and deal
with it later problem is it gets bigger
it's like a dead gum splinter in your
hand
yeah so in this situation it's okay if
he puts all of his effort it becomes
this is our
snowball and we're just going to put
everything towards promise sometimes
people go by crap then
that's right that's right so you have to
be completely disciplined here yeah it's
like
it's you are you're death on your dead
snowball i mean you're game on
gazelle intense focused hitting it hard
all that kind of stuff
and if you're doing all of that then
yeah that you can use the extra money to
go either direction but you're still
going to end up paying it
so uh all it does is it slows down the
speed of the one thing if you
if you have a bigger payment and speak
to
the details i've heard this from you
before you know forbearance sounds like
oh
what a break what a relief but if you
don't look at the fine details you could
get yourself in a really sticky
situation where
maybe it's actually there's lots of lots
of levels to this to where it's not
true forbearance if it's going to be a
penalty later on yeah
well back during covet you know people
were offered forbearance on their
mortgage
and what that meant was don't pay a
couple payments
uh and people were like ah i don't have
a pay payment that's awesome
it's like no no it's coming it's coming
in september
and you're going to pay them all and
catch them all up or they're going to do
this thing called foreclosure
that goes right after forbearance so uh
yes yeah bad plan so no you don't kick
the can down the road unless you have to
or unless you're just really dialed in
and you're going to use this to your
advantage but i would not
use the word forbearance in most cases
to purposefully get behind it's
how to get caught up is what it really
means uh that's what the purpose of it
is when you do a forbearance on a
mortgage
in a traditional situation that means
you're like four payments behind
and they agree to uh a payment and a
half for eight months
eight halves as the four holes catches
you up
in addition to your regular payment
that's a forbearance a catch-up plan
and i'm not talking about like
mayonnaise i'm talking about catching up
right so
you know that that's what you're looking
for and that's what the word really
means
and so just beware because anytime
somebody starts talking about you
skipping payments or anything else
they gonna get that money that's what
you need to remember